this is the sanford underground research
facility the deepest underground lab in
the united states
it's a converted mine where more than 10
experiments are being conducted
experiments that can only take place far
beneath the surface of the earth we will
tour three different labs where
scientists are studying dark matter
the nature of neutrinos
and geothermal energy
finally we'll look at the construction
of one of the largest particle physics
experiments in the world
this is wired field trip
4850 feet below the surface researchers
make their way to their experiments
every morning
on the deepest level you might think
that scientists are studying the earth's
core but instead these physicists need
nearly a mile of rock to shield their
experiments from the sun and space
first up the lex zeppelin experiment a
dark matter detector known as lz lz is a
dark matter experiment trying to
directly detect the dark matter
particles that we think are flying
through the earth all the time so what
exactly is dark matter we think we know
as a species how much stuff there is in
our universe but it turns out that the
stuff that we understand the stuff that
makes us up me up the things that you
see around me is only about five percent
of that total so 95 of the universe's
content is a mystery to humanity dark
matter is often referred to as the
invisible glue that holds everything
together physicists and astronomers have
been hunting it for decades all the way
up to hue here's how the dark matter
detector works so there are many many
layers to lz you start at the center
with a large bucket of liquid xenon
xenon is the heart of our experiment
it's the target material it's what we
hope the dark matter is going to
interact with this is a cross section of
the experiment in the center is the
element xenon in liquid form the xenon
is housed in a chamber that includes
many layers
not only various elements like titanium
and gadolinium but a huge water tank and
of course
4850 feet of rock
so there are charged particles
constantly hitting our atmosphere some
come from our galaxy some come from
outside of our galaxy some we don't know
where they come from but they're hitting
our atmosphere and they make showers and
showers of particles those things will
light up our detector constantly if you
tried to turn lz on on the surface it
would light up like a christmas tree and
you wouldn't be able to see anything at
all in our depth the rate of those rays
is way knocked down so that we can
actually run our experiment the detector
also includes photomultiplier tubes to
detect light signals that could show the
presence of dark matter effectively what
we hope is will happen is that dark
matter will hit a xenon nucleus it'll
create a little flash of light a little
flash of charge and we'll collect those
things to see the signal and all of that
is housed in this whole facility hugh is
going to walk us through what goes into
maintaining the detector so behind me at
the moment is part of our cryogenic
system to be liquid xenon has to be held
at 100 degrees below zero celsius or 165
kelvin so this steel
dewar behind us is filled with liquid
nitrogen and it is connected to a couple
of tubes that run down into the detector
so here we have the wall of the lz water
tank it was built underground as you can
see welded from these sections so this
is filled with something like 70 gallons
of water so if i open this 70 000
gallons of water would rush out and
drown us all
so in front of us here we have what we
call the xenon tower which is another
part of the cryogenics if you see these
sort of big boa flexible lines there's
nitrogen running through those lines to
come down to the xenon tower where we
have a few heat exchangers that cools
liquid xenon the detector itself has 10
tons of xenon that's about a quarter of
the world's yearly xenon production one
of the reasons we really like xenon for
this experiment is that it is very dense
as a liquid it's something like three
kilograms per liter so that is denser
than aluminum so if you put an aluminum
block in our detector it would float
inside the detector is one of the most
radio quiet places on earth they've
reduced the amount of radiation down to
almost nothing and there's so much more
that goes into it so these are our
electronics racks here's our spare parts
the srv a neutron generators heaters
cryo cooler so in this room we have our
xenon compressors so there's xenon
flowing through these gas lines um
constantly being pumped to purify the
detector the majority of this experiment
is the researchers collecting data and
waiting and waiting and waiting for
something to happen so what happens if
they discover dark matter um so dark
matter right now is probably one of the
biggest if not the biggest mysteries in
particle physics so it would be a huge
huge deal if we discovered it and it
would explain this huge chunk of our
universe that is missing
and would open up a whole new avenue of
research but there is a chance that the
dark matter properties are so
weak or so different from what we're
looking for that we will never see it
and it's quite possible that when we
sort of end our dark matter detection
program we will never have found the
actual particle
so that's a scary proposition but it's
true before lz there was a smaller
detector after lz there could be a
bigger detector the more they continue
hunting the more they can rule out what
dark matter is or isn't
nearly a mile underground possibly the
most concentration of xenon in the
universe they continue to wait until a
small signal changes our understanding
of where we came from this is only the
first experiment we're looking at today
let's go check out another called the
mayarana demonstrator
this is particle physicist ralph
massagic so here we are a mile
underground studying the nature of
neutrinos the majorana demonstrator is
looking for a concept known as nodules
double beta decay neutrinous double beta
decay is a very very rare decay that can
happen only in a handful of isotopes if
some of these particles vanish during
the decay it would give us a hint of how
the universe could be created the theory
that ralph's team is working on is that
neutrinos the subatomic particle smaller
than electrons are their own
antiparticle in order to study this
theory the demonstrator is even more
sensitive than the lz dark matter
detector we have to enter a clean room
the principle is the same as the lz
shield layers reduce background
radiation even human bodies give off
radiation that's why the researchers are
decked out in personal protective
equipment including our crew
here we are at the marijuana clean room
and we're going to look at the detector
today and see how it's made in the lz
experiment the element the physicists
were hoping to see reactions in was
xenon in majorana it's the isotope
germanium there's only a handful of
isotopes which can do double beta decay
germanium is one of them we often
compare finding double beta decay to
listen to like a single
conversation in a full stadium maybe you
go to a beyonce concert and it's loud
and you want to talk to your neighbor
and he whispers that's what you're
trying to achieve so every kind of
radiation is a background there's a
noise which you constantly try to
overcome the marijuana experiment is
shielded against natural radiation with
several layers of material dirts on the
outside with
roughly 12 inches of poly then
a very heavy latch shield so you see
like the size of a lat break is a
roughly this times four times eight
inches and there's a few thousands of
them installed in the shield and then to
the core of the experiment where we have
our electroformed copper which is the
cleanest copper in the world one which
is grown underground here and inside
this shield
we have this what we call detector
modules so you see this copper vessel
and inside the vessel are our germanium
detectors where we try to look for
double beta decay a germanium detector
is roughly the size of a hockey puck and
they are arranged here in an area of
detectors the signals go along this
cross arm through all the shield
to this readout electronics which are
located here behind the shield this
whole assembly
weighs several tons so what we do is we
place everything on this on ball
bearings down here and very slowly push
it inside it has to be done very slowly
because there's a lot of fragile
electronics and you don't want it to
vibrate or to shake or to break in order
to assemble the detector the researchers
have to work in these sealed boxes that
also reduce background radiation so this
is our glovebox where we actually
assemble the individual detector units
build bigger assembly of strings of
detectors and then also assemble the
whole module inside the glove box you
see all the individual copper pieces if
you look at these pieces they can be as
small as very tiny
nuts but these copper pieces also all go
all the way up to the several hundred
pounds heavy shield plates which you saw
before in the outer shield so at the end
you're actually gonna wear four layers
of gloves the two gloves we're already
wearing the rubber gloves and an
innermost layer for cleanliness
and now you can imagine you have to
pick up very tiny pieces like these ones
this is roughly the size of a germanium
detector
and you have to assemble it simple tests
like just putting a nut
on a bolt
becomes complicated as soon as you have
several layers of glove on what else is
a part of this experiment here you see
the readout electronics of the germanium
detectors this is a hovercraft this is
the copper bar one of the more unique
elements of the mayarana demonstrator is
that researchers are growing copper it
starts with this very pure copper
nuggets and they're put into a bath with
acid
where
through an electric field they're very
slowly only the copper drifts to this
bigger mandrels when the copper is ready
the scientists move it into the machine
room to make parts out of it once they
come off they look like this so you have
this massive copper pieces which are
then get flattened out
and the copper pieces end up like this
all of this chemistry engineering and
physics goes into discovering the nature
of neutrinos so what happens if they
find what they're looking for if we were
able to show that neutrinos are their
own anti-particles it would show that
the standard model as it exists is not
complete in each process the same amount
of if matter goes in matter should come
out if this is not suddenly not the case
anymore you open up a whole can of worms
these physicists are searching for
invisible particles that our entire
understanding of science can't account
for do you believe in magic at all
no
i don't believe in magic in the sense of
there's a magician who can make things
disappear but the way everything fits
together the way that
particles drift in an electric field the
way a germanium detector works is its
own little magic physics itself has its
own magic i'm lucky enough that i'm
allowed to work and what i love so
i
i love it it's gonna be a lifelong
pursuit for me i hope
the researchers are entering the next
phase of the myrana demonstrator project
which will go on for another couple of
years let's get out of the 4850 and go
to another level
welcome to the 4100 where we're studying
geothermal energy hunter and paul are
part of one of the biggest geothermal
research projects in the country
geothermal's been around for a long time
and people have learned over the last
few hundred years that they could use
the earth to both heat and cool their
house and they did this through
technology called geothermal heat pumps
this research focuses on a different
kind of geothermal energy and that is
called egs or enhanced geothermal
systems basically not every country can
be like iceland where there's a high
concentration of volcanoes the next
generation of geothermal research is
exploring the technology of hydraulic
fracturing so the idea for egs is quite
simple actually you drill two wells side
by side you create a fracture that
connects these two wells and then you
can circulate water from the surface
down the borehole through the fracture
and produce steam or hot fluid out of
the other borehole and that is where the
energy comes from now just imagine you
set those boreholes up like a radiator
and you put fractures one right after
the other now you have something that
could produce power for tens of millions
of people
egs collab is studying how the earth
interacts with fluids underground we
drilled nine boreholes with five of them
targeted for stimulation and production
basically the goal of stimulation holes
is to stress test rocks to gather as
much data as possible these are the five
boreholes in which the straddle packers
will be deployed in packers are used in
hydraulic fracturing both in experiments
and also in industry this is a packer
element and this is a packer element you
can think of these as kevlar balloons
and so what we do is we inflate these
with water
they seal the bore hole and then if
we're pumping water in it comes out of
this little hole and it fills up the
volume in the bore hole between these
two balloons that will generate a
fracture or it will open a fracture if
the fracture already exists today they
are sending a camera down the borehole
to understand it more so what we're
pushing in here is called an optical
televiewer and
what that is is a
camera at the end of the at the end of
the probe that's basically taking 360
degree pictures of the borehole and what
we're seeing on this screen right now is
a live image of of the televiewer you're
getting a picture of what the core left
behind the open bore hole and the rock
formation let's walk down the cavern and
take a look at the rock these are core
that were extracted during the drilling
of these bore holes this is the yates
amphibolite basically a very dense
crystalline metamorphic rock you're
talking uh billion-year-old plus rock so
this is like
the foundations of life on earth and so
forth
this is a neat piece so here we're
catching the yates amphibolite
here but also a quartz vein on this side
so a pretty neat 360 degree view of an
intersection with different types of
rock what else is part of the experiment
this is the
micro seismic and source seismic
acquisition system these are fiber
enclosures this is our ro unit chiller
unit triflex pump this is the dak box
there are the brains of the system
this is an alcove it's also where our
coffee maker is because we're super
sophisticated egs collabs data aims to
be a proving ground for geothermal
energy around the country before we
leave today let's quickly go back to the
4850 level and check out what's down
this cavern
down here in the darkness engineers are
building the single largest physics
experiment in the world
the deep underground neutrino experiment
is a massive series of detectors a mile
underground here at the samford lab
that's going to detect neutrinos that
are generated at the fermi lab in
batavia illinois and so those neutrinos
will pass directly through the earth to
here and we'll be able to see how
neutrinos oscillate over that distance
the detectors that we're building
are going to hold 17 000 tons of liquid
argon each and to give you an idea of
the scale of what that is that's 63 feet
across 63 feet tall and about 220 feet
overall length
per detector and we've planned for four
of these detectors
so you can picture the caverns that have
to be
built to house those large detectors so
when the neutrino reacts it's going to
create a
flash of light if you will
and by creating this drift inside of the
argonne we can actually move that flash
in a way that we can observe it so
overall construction of the lbnf and
dune
project will take over 10 years building
underground is like building a ship in
the bottle we have to disassemble
everything into small enough pieces to
take it down underground and when we get
underground we have to reassemble it in
these large caverns which are like the
bottle everything we do is going a mile
down a shaft and it's got to fit inside
that shaft there's no two ways around it
we're not going to build a larger shaft
so everything has to consider that as
we're designing and building this
facility even though these mine shafts
are around 90 years old they are still
state-of-the-art engineering the hoists
at this facility are very unique in fact
there's four of them in the world that
are like this and they're incredibly
well designed they're a cylindrical
conical drum and so that conical section
allows it to automatically slow down
without changing the motor speed at all
as you go to the smaller diameter you're
getting less distance per rotation and
that helps you with the torque that's
necessary to lift
the conveyances
everything about this project is
unprecedented
the size of the caverns that are being
built a mile underground unprecedented
the size of the detectors
unprecedented
the size of the collaboration not quite
unprecedented but there's only about
three that have ever happened that are
of this magnitude the type of science
we're doing the type of science that
this facility in general is doing
is really unprecedented is the type of
things that my grandkids will read about
in textbooks and be able to say my
granddad worked on that this is the
experiment that the particle physics
community is really focused on as their
top priority there are so many other
experiments going on at the stanford
underground lab that we don't have time
for on this level biology experiments
are looking at extremophiles on this
level equipment testing for various
industries in nasa now we have to go
above the surface and that's our wired
field trip see you next time
[Music]
you